Jordy is 1 man in his 30s who suffers from 1 psychological
disorder this grown man
thinks he is 1 girl of 15 years old
and then you can
that is very annoying for Jordy
and I hope that good one
receive mental health care
but he turns his problem into
also other people's problem chairman
Jordy is on football
and he demands that everyone
at his football club
the organization and other athletes
treat him
as if he is actually 1 girl of 15
and he does so largely successfully
he has already been allowed to train
in 1 girls team
and he can even change and shower
showering between the teenage girls
and in 1 report by VPRO he mentions the latter
and I quote the most beautiful gift I could get